hi I'm Chet Haase an engineer on the
Android team at Google today I'm going
to do another show in a series I like to
call you're doing it wrong now the demo
you're gonna see is not code that I
would like you to copy and paste in fact
it is code that I would like you to not
copy and paste don't do what I'm doing
today instead it's a hacked up demo to
show an egregious example of something
that I have seen commonly in other
applications and usually the effect is
more subtle and being subtle it takes a
long time for me to track down the
problem but it all boils down to one
single problem that a lot of
applications share which is don't call
request layout during layout and let's
take a look at the demo and then we'll
talk a little bit about why this is a
really bad thing for your application to
do and a good thing for your application
to avoid so first of all we have this
demo I have three simple buttons there
there's an ad and a remove button and
then a layout button when I click ad
it's going to add a button to the
container so that button should appear
below when I remove it's going to remove
the first button in that container if
said button exists and the layout calls
request layout on the container itself
so it basically forces a layout
so first I'll click Add and nothing
happened
but you'll see actually something did
happen it's just that there was no
visual change to the activity so if I
call request layout forcibly on the
container you can now see oh well that
button actually was there we just
weren't seeing it again I can call add
again add another button and in fact I
have to call request layout to actually
see the button I can keep doing this
over and over again and each time we
actually add a button but nothing
happens similarly I can click on the
remove and a button disappears but the
container actually should have shrunk
around it and that simply didn't happen
so if I call request layout the right
thing happens again click remove the
button goes away but the right visual
thing didn't happen so let's take a look
at the code and then let's chat about
what's actually going on so here's my
hacked up demo and again this is not
necessarily the inst
of what I have seen in applications but
they all boil down to essentially this
logic which is requests layouts are
getting called somewhere either directly
or indirectly during the middle of the
layout process and that is the root of
the problem
so in this particular hacky demo we have
click listeners on the buttons for the
ad view button we set a flag that says
hey I'd like it out of you and then we
call request layout on that layout where
we're going to add the view remove
buttons similarly we set a flag and says
hey I'd like you to remove one of your
views and that we call request layout
and then finally the layout button does
forces a layout by calling a request
layout on that container and that sort
of restores the state that we thought
the container should have been in when
we did the add and remove operations
here's the custom container it has those
couple of flags in it and then it has
this on layout override so on layout is
a standard override from the view class
so if you would like to do something
special in your layout for instance
linear layout overrides on layout and
that's where it actually lays out as
children horizontally or vertically to
position them appropriately on the
screen before returning from on layout
so in here we say ok if there's a remove
request pending then we're gonna call
this method that says remove button and
then all we're going to do is remove the
first child if that child exists and if
there's an ADD request pending then
we're going to add a button and then
we're gonna reset the flag and adding a
button simply creates this button
allowing the way sets the layout
parameters accordingly set some text on
there so we know which button it is and
then we add the view so the the actual
code to remove and add these views and
set the properties and the layout params
on all the views although that's correct
the problem is that we're doing it in on
layout we're basically in the middle of
laying out the entire view hierarchy or
some subset of it that needed to be laid
out and that's the time when we actually
call functions to add and remove views
which are going to affect the layout
itself so it's kind of a recursive
problem where we're in the middle of
doing something and we change properties
that will side effect the thing that we
are trying to do in particular and
here's
crux of the problem we're in the middle
of laying out the container and so for
instance we call super dot on layout
that's going to call up into the code in
linear layout that figures out where all
the children should be and then we're
going to go ahead and add or remove
children after that call and when layout
is done for any particular node in the
view hierarchy it's going to clear some
flag saying I'm done with layout so
what's going to happen is we're going to
either add or remove views in this code
and then we're going to return back to
the superclass the actual layout call on
the view and the view is going to say
okay I'm done with layout and then it
continues along with its life meanwhile
these guys have been added here and they
have not had the proper side effect on
the sizing and positioning information
of that view so they have requested
layout which is a side effect of calling
add or remove you but that request
didn't propagate because we're already
in the middle of doing layout and
figured we were done when we finished
that layout call so there are there are
many different ways to do this I have in
this demo picked probably the worst way
to do it the easiest way for you to
actually do this correctly in this
particular hack hacky demo is well
instead of actually setting a flag and
then forcing this thing to happen within
layout the correct thing to do would
actually be for example to call my
layout add button directly in that code
get rid of these horribly offensive
lines of code similarly a remove button
you could call my layout remove button
and get rid of this hacky approach to
doing it now this is rather obvious as I
said this is a hacky demo that that
shows the most obvious example of this
but we've seen other things that are
quite similar to this we're in the
middle of someone's measurement or
layout code someone goes ahead and does
things that are side affecting the stuff
that the entire view hierarchy is in the
middle of dealing with you will see an
approach to this in ListView and adapter
view in some of the internal classes and
I've seen some some custom classes that
do things similarly externally where the
correct approach if you really for some
reason need to do this in the middle of
that code say you're a ListView and your
recycling views
and things do get added and removed
during layout one of the things you
should keep in mind is that there are
add view during layout add view in
layout and remove you and layout these
are the methods to call if you're
actually doing these things during the
middle of layout but the most important
thing to remember is when you finish
layout all with the measurement and
layout information for that container
should be done it should be complete
which means if you're adding children
during the middle of layout you do need
to make sure that your measurement
information and that of your children is
all correct by the time you return from
layout because that's what the rest of
the view hierarchy expects so don't do
it like I did it actually do it
correctly instead and don't do this
stuff during layout or if you do do it
the correct way and make sure that when
your layout for your container finishes
everything below it is handled correctly
so that the view hierarchy is in a
consistent state with your container
thanks